next up we have dan mikulinso who's
going to tell us about universality in
neural networks
hi
yeah so
we'll talk about universality in your
networks
which is a result we obtained uh earlier
this year together with uh
which was here yesterday
and i'll use the opportunity to tell
about some recent developments and this
will be a joint work
with the thai glasgow and an independent
work of the adam krukowski i will tell
you about it
and so but what is the basic setting i
want to consider
so for simplicity a
two-layer neural network
at a random initialization
okay so basically same setting from
before
but here we have a random function it's
composed of a sum
of independent linear function composed
with a non-linear function that's the
activation
so here x is a vector in rn
and the random weights are generated
independently as the standard gaussians
okay and then we give random signs and
scale basically root of k which which
makes sense when you want to talk about
universality
right so each one of those is a random
function your sum in k random functions
and normalizing so
standard reasoning says that it should
look
this should converge to some gaussian
limit there should be some central limit
theorem
oh yeah it should be plus minus one here
inside thanks right random signs for
each function otherwise
just to to center it
yeah thanks
so indeed this converges
to a limit
in the space of functions and this was
observed by in the 90s by radford nil
and according to nil clt as k goes to
infinity
the law of this random function
converges to a gaussian process
okay and then hearing a gaussian process
is any any random function whose finite
dimensional margin is
jointly gaussian
um all right so this is neil's result
and since the 90s there have been many
subsequent works
generalizing it to different
architectures
and and with different metrics but but
the lardo almost all of those results
can be classified into two to
two sets of results either they were
asymptotic
so they only said something about the
existence of the limit
okay or they were finite dimensional
results but that if you take some subset
of rn or of the sphere and you look at
the induced m-dimensional vector then
this vector converges at some rate to a
gaussian in rm
okay
and and and the question is can you say
something about the convergence
which is independent of a sample can you
give a rate of convergence for the
random function itself
okay so
we want to prove a non-asymptotic
convergence bound in the space of
functions
so before we can say anything we need to
understand how to metalize
this convergence
okay so
a natural
metric to introduce
on
say l2 of the sphere but it really
doesn't have to be on the sphere are the
transportation matrix
okay so
let me talk about two of those
we call this
a
functional vassal stein distance okay
but basically
if you have two random functions of this
on the sphere you look at the infimum
between all of the couplings
and you integrate the square difference
over the sphere
okay so you want to minimize
the distance in l2 over the sphere
and you can also look at so this is
really the
wasserstein one distance on l2
okay and you can also look at the
stronger metric
which takes the
uniform distance so we're just looking
for a coupling which minimizes the
maximal deviate the am deviation between
the two
the expected maximal deviation between
the two random functions
okay so we want to prove
a
rate of convergence with respect to
those metrics
and that's basically what we do for any
reasonable activation function
and here reasonable means basically that
it's a square integrable with respect to
the gaussian
and
and
we saw some yes
functions
to random elements in l2 of the sphere
the infimum was overall coupling it's
over all measures
who's on l2 of the sphere times l2 of
the sphere such that the first marginal
is f and the second module is f prime
so
this is
thanks
yeah
but anyway it's some way to measure
some metric way to measure the
difference between two random functions
so we want to to use the metric which is
induced from this
can you see a bit more about what that
sounds like i mean
i can think of other simpler metrics
because we can prove it uh
no i mean
i i mean it's natural when you want to
think about infinite dimensional regimes
right because
what i want to say is now if we know how
to prove convergence under this metric
when i take any finite dimensional
sample
i get a bound a convergence bound a
metal convergence mount which does not
depend on the sample size
right i mean i understand it's a very
strong metric but i mean given that you
said that there was basically nothing
that was true before i mean
like you mean if i would prove it in
this do i get a duality no i'm saying
like you know there's a truth yeah we've
been proving like
downs and what
wait like
and uh
it's not that i'm going to use a
coupling i want it i'm going to use a
metallic argument i'm going to use the
inner the inner product of this field
i i want to use the metric of this field
and once i do that that's the natural
that's the natural notion of distance
about it's a natural notion of distance
and then you have coupling arguments
yeah
this
distance is between the classes of the
functions right
this distance is between the classes of
primes right yeah so it's those those
are random elements of l2
but you have so you can think about them
as continuous functions for example and
that would be fine
yes
no but i mean those distributions are
you know equivalent up to measure zero
sets right
so
that was what you were asking
so you can think about
you can think about as a continuous
representative for which one of those
that would be the same
because l2 of the sphere is pretty
boring
okay so
we actually
have a separation in our results and we
separate between activations which are
polynomial
and for this we can we really obtain
results
with respect to the stronger metric
and activations which are general
non-polynomial and we only obtain
results with respect to the weaker
metric
but
we actually know now how to
get results for general activation
in the stronger method if you if you do
not
require the weights to be gaussian
okay and as i said before what you get
you get a
a central limit theorem a quantitative
central limit for you know arbitrary
samples which do not depend on the size
of the subject
so yeah in the time i have left i i just
want to give you like to explain the
main idea and you know what else could
you do other than what we did
right so the main challenge improving
this infinite dimensional center limit
theorem is that if you would try to use
any central limit theorem you know
the rate of convergence always
deteriorates with the dimension
right so none of them would simply apply
infinite dimensions and there's a very
simple observation here which you can
make for polynomial functions for
polynomial activations
is that if the activation is polynomial
then every you know random function you
you had in the sum is a polynomial
is a degree p polynomial whatever and
when you sum degree people in numbers
then you function you you end up which
is zero degree people in normal so even
though it lives in l2 of the sphere it
is constrained to stay in some finite
dimensional space
and then you can use
like existing center limit right right
so the plan is to embed
the law of the neural network in a
finite dimensional euclidean space and
invoke the central limit theorem results
but we do need the embedding to be
compatible with the metric
and uh
so this works for polynomial activation
and for general activation you can just
approximately probably
and that's more or less the plan
so let me just illustrate a very very
simple uh
case but but really everything
generalizes from this case is that if
the function the activation function is
monomial
so it takes t to t to the d for some
natural number b
and and the way to make this compatible
with the inner product is just to know
that
if you if you apply it to an inner
product
right you just take this power ordinal
product
this corresponds to linearizing the
inner product
in the tensile space
so the diff power of an inner product is
the inner product between the d tensor's
power
in the tensile space so the way to embed
the network in a finite dimensional
space is right if this is the activation
and we're summing care of those guys we
can rewrite
this term just as an inner product in
the terms of space
use linearity and here we have a
random vector
in some high dimensional but finite with
finite dimension in gradient space and
we're just tensoring we're taking it's
inner product with some tensor power and
this gives a natural definition for a
gaussian process
right because now let's define a
gaussian process by just taking any
gaussian vector in the tens of space
and heating it
with the vector x
so this has a gaussian node
and it defines the gaussian process over
the entire space
right and and with this perspective if
you want to prove bounds
with this transportation metric
right so we want to
bound the supremum deviation
so
we can decouple
the distance from the random vector we
had before to the gaussian vector from
the dependence of x
and then just by using cauchy verts
this is a vector on the sphere
so it has norm one
we just need to understand the distance
within a sum of independent random
vectors
in some high dimensional space and a
gaussian vector
right so this is just the central limit
theorem now in finite dimensions
and indeed
you know
so so you can use off-the-shelf central
limit theorems uh
but actually something we've we put
before that there are special central
limit theorem
which uh take accounting the special
structure of those random vectors
and then
[Music]
when you put all of those things
together you can prove that when the
activation is monomial
then you get something which is a very
very explicit rate of convergence which
is very similar to what you what you
know from finite dimensions right so it
decreases at the rate
which is proportional to the square root
of the number of summons
okay and uh
yeah let me
let me just say about uh
you know one thing which appeared in the
book is that we have to bound the
covariance
of this random vector
for gaussian vectors it's just a result
of integration by parts
and and one thing we did
now is to generalize those bounds for
more general
distributions right so it doesn't have
to be
a gaussian
and let me
let me just end by saying that
that was one way to embed
the measure into a finite dimensional
space but there are other ways you don't
need to embed it into a space of
monomials
so so that's the idea of adam krukowski
who embedded those
networks into a space of harmonic
polynomials and when you embed it into a
space of harmonic polynomials then you
don't need to worry about the covariance
structure because everything is
orthogonal
so we managed to obtain much much better
results also for non-polynomial
activations
i think i'll stop
okay welcome back to the question of
you know why
[Music]
so you know if you have this thing you
are interested in your eyes you talking
yeah so that's not something i know how
to do using those results differently
right so
one thing which i can immediately say is
that you can use the same ideas
to bound the convergence of the ntk
in the space of kevins
like it should be
i believe it should be possible to do it
uh
another another thing that
i thought about and i think that you
should be able to do i don't know how to
do it
and so there's a recent result of peter
which relies on previous results that
you have
adversarial examples at a random
initialization
and then
both this new result and but for already
for the order results there is one
constraint which does not allow the size
of the network to go to infinity
and you know when the size of the
network goes to infinity then you know
it has a limit so maybe it's enough to
prove something for the limit right so
that's one thing that you could do it's
i i thought it would be it's not as easy
as i thought reasoning about the other
several examples in gaussian processors
and
but i don't know i don't know whether it
works or not
[Music]
all right let's thank that again
and we start up at 1 pm
[Music]